you said you wanted to talk about Algol
60 well is 60 things somebody has said
it's 60th anniversary release which is
rights I mean it did come out in 1960
which is why it was called Algol 60 and
so yes it is 16 years old 60 years of
Algol 60 birthday howl 60 it's another
of these that was tremendously
influential at the time and a flag of
that everybody could rally around but in
the end it was designed by a committee
and despite all their attempts to be
reasonable and not too demanding
individual Commission members tried like
heck to get their favorite things in
there regardless of how expensive they
were to implement and Saltz mightily or
tended to if they didn't get them in I'm
gonna start off with an Al Gore 60
version of we've done a video on this
Ackerman's function now Algol 60 one of
its famous selling points was that at
last you'll be able to do truly
desperately recursive things like a
common dysfunction because this time and
there was a big punch up in the
committee about it basically say do we
want to do recursion it's bound to give
us a bad name cuz it'll be slow and
everybody said now we've got to do it
you know it's no good saying things like
factorial and Fibonacci can be done not
properly recursively in loops
essentially things like a command combi
so we got to do it it's it's part of our
duty as to what how God's going to be so
this is the way it came out and it
worked just fine I think I can even
explain it to you using on here the
comments of thing okay so I've just
dragged over the word begin later on in
the 60s decade when si came upon us they
used open curly brace and close curly
brace to define a block of code alcohol
is much more of a Bo's that uses begin
and end could you miss those yes in fact
I'm no one here look
the initial begin is up at the top and
this matches with that end but hidden in
here as part of this program there is a
do loop here but to show the extent of
the do loop not curly braces like in C
begin and end so here's my big it and
here's the matching end that goes with
it oh it's sort of working but then what
happens after that well let's cut to the
chase and let me tell you this thing
first of all defines the Ackermann
procedure that is going to get called
and it does it obviously in Algol 60
nomenclature partway down the procedure
stops and the bottom half is the main
program now here is another contentious
discussion point it's not immediately
obvious until you look at the structure
of the program that down here where it
says integer m n that is not a part of
the Ackermann function it's part of the
main program so when you move on to C
which you can remember is eight or nine
years downstream of the Algol 60
Committee so many lessons have been
learned and the feeling was Algol is
terrible sometimes for you to have to
mentally pause the program to discover
where the main program begins wouldn't
it be nice to flag it up with something
like main which was obligatory yes it
would it's a very good idea so if we go
through this line by line we've got to
begin and then that next line says
integer procedure Ackerman M n okay it's
a procedure no abbreviation no ability
to use proc or anything like that it's a
procedure it delivers an integer no
abbreviations allowed it's gotta be
integer not int and what it's saying is
Ackerman takes two arguments m and n but
at the end of the day when it's done its
work it delivers back an integer that's
why you say it's an integer procedure
okay so it's heralding the idea of
what's actually called a function more
in C a thing that delivers back a value
in integer or float or
characters or whatever here we go then
are now here comes something that we
will absolutely be stumbling over in
future discussion you had to say that
the incoming arguments M and then were
not very clever ones there were Mayor
values so you actually have to say not
just M and n are integers but also the M
and n are passed by value and not by
reference which was the most general
mechanism so all of that taught London
is just the procedure heading then
there's something which really does put
alarm among human colon equals if M
equals naught then n plus 1 else if well
or whatever the rule was in algal sixty
that you've returned the value of a
function not with the reserved word
return which by time C came along began
the standard was it you say return thing
or whatever
no you returned it in a very logical way
by doing a pseudo assignment to the name
of the true Savior you're saying the
whole a command effect becomes the
action of this procedure body here which
are right act on the right hand side
Ackerman becomes the truth or falsehood
all if M equals nor then delivered back
n plus 1 so the value of M plus 1
whatever that says 6 or something would
get put into not a real variable but put
a pseudo variable that is there to
return just the result of the procedure
now that can be so confusing for
beginners to say that it's confusing for
me right now you declare it is a
procedure but that's what it is so the
obvious way to return its results is not
to say return n but to say acumen
becomes this thing using making it look
like a pseudo assignment statement some
people love it some people hate it but
you see you can have arbitrary
complexity on the right hand side it's
saying well if M is naught and then you
deliver the result is n plus 1 and
here's the notorious bit that we've
already covered in a video somewhere
other
as if n is naught then you cook up
ackerman again now that's your first
example of a recursive call you're
calling your back ermine within Ackerman
but with arguments and minus one on one
this time and if that is not true
if it isn't naught then the most general
recursive call of Ackerman is a comment
of n minus 1 and then the second
argument from hell is itself a call
Ackerman to work out your second
parameter and isn't that that drives is
super exponential eventually but that's
the end of the whole thing it may not be
obvious to you but that thing they're
saying it else Ackerman M n minus 1 the
next line says integer mmm what's that
got to do with this function nothing at
all it's part of them a program because
you see you have given what would be a
one-liner definition of what you want to
deliver into Ackerman so that clearly
with its semicolon at the end of it is
all you need to define what hakama to
deliver so you didn't use a beginning
end because she didn't have to it was an
integer procedure there's the header and
it was a one-liner pseudo assignment
statement returned the value oh god I
used to love teaching this to raw
beginners so you had sort of put this
paper down down to but not including
integer m n is the procedure body but by
the time we come through integer n n
it's extra declarations in the main
program here already to define the
procedure Ackerman but now these are
common or garden integers were going to
use so integer variables basically M&N
fair enough and then we get on to a
piece of code that is very very similar
mean see very similar in whatever
language you do basically just putting
to do loops inside each other to
investigate the low value parameter end
of the Ackermann function so we've got
here for n different but similar you
know you can think of a for loop in C
with its parentheses in each colons
inside it but this is very similar for M
becomes 0 that's the star value
step one step it up in Warren as we go
around the loop until it reaches three
do with the following
but then straightaway nested inside that
it doesn't just say do it says do begin
there's a no for loop for n from naught
step one until six do and then here the
next nightmare did Algol 60 have
standardly defined input/output no but
you complicated and caused too many
fistfights in the committee said it's
implementing implementation dependent
what your import output will look like
it's always a mess and there's nothing
to do with us but your programming
manual will define for you what the
input/output conventions are for your
compilers running on your computer at
your university or whatever so I've got
here and this particular version from
rosetta code they've used out integer
which is as good as anything so out
integer an out string they're using
actually here and the way they're doing
this is just putting out the values for
M and N increasing in fact you know as
we all know the first zeros values are
just the numbers themselves are like 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 and so on so yes you can see
from the printed out numbers there it
works just fine but I think in terms of
impenetrable obscurity it is not good
the worst bit is the fact that you can
carry on after what is obvious at the
end of the integer procedure definition
because there's a semicolon there no
extra begins or ends to help you they're
not necessary I can't quite recall
whether it would have been wrong to put
them in but anyway it was his heart was
in the right place but the trouble is it
was a committee and this is what came
out of it these things you're talking
about now with the benefit of hindsight
and having used C for many years would
you have thought of these things then or
is this stuff that you can just see in
Hanson you get a lot of it you know in
size the thing I think a lot of people
said Wow
in the real live engineering and science
world it might you might have some need
for a factorial but you could always
calculate it by going around a loop
because it's a primitive recursive
function and when people said but what
do you really need recursion for that
would matter to me the answer is
probably nothing a lot of people did say
and rightly once a recursion becomes
part of the scenery people will work out
how to implement it far more efficiently
and it is actually for some problems a
very very elegant way of coping with it
but you need to be sure that your
implementation if recursion has been
done by somebody with at least the
talents of Ken Thomason to make sure it
doesn't run hideously hideously slowly
so there we are
it works Algol 60 did the job
it wasn't exactly obvious syntax as a
method for doing economist e where the
main program begins but nevertheless it
did the job how did things improve and
get more efficient by the time C was
developed to fruition roughly eight to
ten years later well rather than spend
ages doing that myself I will refer you
to one of my videos which is about the
Ackermann function what was it the most
difficult program to compute question
mark is what we call it yes the crush
models are important as we went on to
find different more difficult oh yes yes
we discovered it wasn't coming we
discovered busy beavers far worse but
that's another story
no in the Ackerman info block I think
you will find if you leave it in that
video there is a link out there to
either a package of stuff all to a
listing of the C version of how to do
the Aquin function let me say right here
and now I did it that way to prove a
point it is very very old-fashioned see
it is original Kernighan and Ritchie see
where you specified the type of the
incoming arguments to functions
separately
from the proceed ahead you had like a
little separate well like in Algol 60
you said in teh be inside not up at the
top so please don't castigate me because
at the time I was interested to see if
my original usage of C to show that
Ackman's function worked would still
stand up in the modern compiler and
thank him GCC you did not fake a
theological approach and refused to
compile me you just understood it was
old-fashioned but it was okay and it
works pick out some things about Algol
60 or send it in context I say okay the
big three by the late fifties early
sixties in a sense were you either a
coding this whole thing down so this
function works it has the correct
behavior but it's not satisfactory
because